à la sortie du pressoir ce jus de raisin
à bien plus que d'habitude la saveur de
l'effort et de l'incertitude
vigneron de père en fils depuis 1858
jean-daniel appartient à la cinquième
génération
il a repris l'exploitation familiale
avec sa famille lit à 21 ans avec la
crise sanitaire
ils ont été obligées de réorganiser leur
travail et faire face aussi aux caprices
du temps trop sec
après le vent des enfers voici venu le
temps des vendanges et le millésime 2000
27 ans millésime très particulier un
s'en souviendra je pense encore
longtemps
il a fallu réorganiser un peu le mode de
travail au niveau de l'équipe qui
travaille avec nous donc nous nos
salariés
donc on a pris toutes les dispositions
en interne pour protéger à la fois nos
salariés et aussi nos clients qui
viennent qui viennent chez nous pour
déguster pour acheter du vin alors la
situation climatique est effectivement
de cette année a aussi un impact sur sur
la ligne donc les feuilles ont brûlé
sous l'effet direct du soleil vous avez
aussi des phénomènes de d'échaudage donc
qui se traduisent par par une perte de
jeu et puis un dessèchement des raisons
donc tout ça c'est un impact aussi sur
sur la quantité de raisin et la calandre
la quantité de jus qui sera récoltée à
l'issue des bandages indépendants ils
ont fait le choix de produire et surtout
vendre leurs vins bio d'alsace
directement aux consommateurs aux
restaurateurs et aux cavistes
mais au début du confinement tout
s'arrête mars avril mai c'est près de 60
% de chiffre d'affaires en moins à
partir du moment où une marche c'est le
moment où ça ou ça redémarre normalement
des groupes qui sont inscrits sur
l'agenda pour faire des one two des
séminaires qui doivent déguster du vin
et là il n'ya plus il n'y a plus rien
n'y a plus de restauration n'y a plus de
groupe il ya plus de particuliers donc
c'est la douche froide sur l'année on
estime à -15 moins 10% du chiffre
d'affaires durant les trois mois de
confinement la commercialisation chute
lourdement et ce quels que soient les
canaux de distribution les exportations
ont baissé d'un tiers quant au tourisme
il est à l'arrêt complet pour al arnous
directeur de la fédération des vignerons
indépendants sur les 130 millions de
bouteilles vendues en moyenne chaque
année ce sont près de 7 millions qui
n'ont pas pu être écoulés pendant cette
période
un manque à gagner dans les trésoreries
et malgré les mesures gouvernementales
de chômage partiel et de prêts garantis
le compte n'y est pas les vignerons ou
peu fait appel au dispositif de chômage
partiel et pour faire part des aides
sectorielles
on peut dire clairement que la
viticulture a été un des grands oubliés
des aides sectorielles
on a eu finir vinicole dans sa globalité
a eu moins de 300 euros dead
je rappelle que la viticulture si le
deuxième
le secteur en balance commerciale à
l'export
secteurs qui sont qui sont aidées à
plusieurs milliards d'euros donc ya pas
de commune mesure
alors si les mois de juin juillet et
août ont offert une bouffée d'oxygène
aux vignerons avec une reprise de
l'activité de près de 10% en plus par
rapport à l'an dernier
l'avenir reste encore très incertain si
les salons de vente ou encore les
marchés de noël surtout en alsace
demeuraient fermées pour des questions
sanitaires